منها رياض ينضم الينا الموسيقار محمود
سرور اهلا بك يسعد صباحك نورنا بصباح
العربيه شكرا على تواجدك معانا
[موسيقى]
صباح الفل
والنور والسرور
في اسباب النجوميه
وقت ما ربنا سبحانه وتعالى بيريد بتحصل من
لقطه من مشهد من قطعه موسيقيه من اي شيء
هو التواصل مع الله سبحانه وتعالى هو اللي
بيوصل لك للناس محبه الناس دي بتكون من
عند ربنا سبحانه وتعالى صعب انك تكسبيها
بالقصد ولكن انت بتكسبيها باعطاء رباني
الله
اهم يعني هذا كمان من حي التواضعك يا
محمود بس انت كمان انشات معهد للموسيقى في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض كيف فكرت فيه
وماذا بتقدموا في هذا المعهد
بصي انا لما جيت فكرت اعمل المعهد ده فكرت
باختصار ان الموضوع يكون خدني يعني حبيت
اني اخدم الناس اللي حبيتني والناس اللي
قربت مني والناس اللي عاملتني كاني منهم
حسيت انهم لما حبوا الكمنجه ثقافه الكمنجه
ما كانتش موجوده كان الاول ثقافه العود في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بشكل عام كانت
ثقافه العود كله كان يحب العود ويحب
الايقاعات والكلام ده ما كانتش في الخريطه
لما الناس حبت كمان جاء بالشكل اللي انا
قدمته وبداوا يفكروا ازاي يعزوها قطر في
بالي على طول فكره ان انا ايه اعمل معهد
كان في البدايه لتعليم الكمنجه عشان اقلب
الناس كمان ده ازاي حاول امنيه اللي هم
بيفكروا فيها يعني يعزفوا زي السرور قوي
شوفوا محمود السرور ده بيعمل ايه بيعمله
زيه يعزفه انت مالك هي المقطوع الاشهر
اللي انا اتشهرت بها في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
في خطر في بالي ان انا اعمل معهد لتعليم
الكمان وكمان فكرت في ان انا اعمل مكون
لفرقه اييي دار اوبرا فرق الدار اوبرا ااا
تكون سعوديه بالكامل كل عناصرها سعوديين
المايسترو والعازفين وكل افراد الفرقه وكل
السعوديين بالكامل كان بالنسبه لي حلم
يعني هو انا شغال فيه لسه وبشتغل عليه
انما ان شاء الله العربيه
اسمعك حاجه مصريه ولا حاجه
يا محمود من اغنيه شبيه الريح يعني بما
انه انت مره في احدى حفلاتك يعني محمد
عبده كان نفسي شوي الكلمات انت طلعت حكيت
لنا المعزوفه هل كان ارتجال ولا كان مرتب
له
والله اقول لك على حاجه هو الموضوع
باختصار ان كل العازفين الموجودين وراء
الفنان خلف الفنان اي عازف موجود لازم
يكون ينقذوا صاحي للي بيحصل لان المسرح
همم
المسرح مليان بالمفاجاه العازف المحترف
لازم يكون شايف ايه اللي بيحصل قدامه في
المسرح فانا طبعا خلف الاستاذ محمد عبده
يا عيني عليه
دائما هو كان بيحط الورق بتاع اللي هو
اللي بيفتكر منه الكلام قدامه على اليمين
المره دي المسرح كان مختلف حطته على
الشمال فهو اول ما اول ما ادور على الكلام
وهو بيدور بيبص على الكلام بص على اليمين
مالهوش فبدا يدور يمين ويسار انا لما شفت
المنظر كده حسيت ان هو مش مش لاقي الورق
فقلت اعمل شئ همم حول به الموقف من سهو
ونسيان الاستاذ محمد عبده الفنان العربي
الفنان الكبير لموقف يعتبر
فدخلت بشكل الاتجاه ليه عشان خاطر همم
اعمل عمليه الهاء
للمستمع الهاء فني برده بحاجه تاثير وهي
صغيره شيء بسيط الناس تسمع همم حاجه عقبال
الاستاذ محمد عبده يشوف الورقه هنا او هنا
ويبدا الموقف ايه شيء شيء ذكاء يعني شباب
بتبقى من العزف او احترافيه ونفضل متابع
مش بس الورقه اللي قدامه ولا يفضل متابع
كل شيء وعينه على الوضع بشكل كامل يعني
واحنا حابين كمان نضل نسمعك في قلبنا
وتعزف لنا وتطربنا في هذا الصباح
شو شغلك
الحب كله
الحب كله الاغنيه دي
ام كلثوم ام كلثوم
[موسيقى]
طيب محمود في اغنيه ثانيه اغنيه انت ملك
ارتبطت باسمك باسم محمود سرور ما الذي
يعني ذلك
بصي انت عيوني
حاضر حاضر عيوني
على قلبي انا حبيته لانه كان سبب
التواصل الكبير اللي حصل بيني وبين الشعب
السعودي بشكل
الانطلاقه انا من التسعينات وانا بسجل
سرعات لكل الفنانين من المحيط الخليج
وباعزف لكل الفنانين وحيد الخليج انما
كانت فتحه الخير من انت مالك بنسمع سوا
سوا
[موسيقى]
الله انت مالك من قبل لا تصبح ملك شكرا يا
محمود السرور شكرا جزيلا لك
معانا تسلم